welcome to markiplier mix
creme brulee coming from
france obviously it is a
dish best served cold much like revenge
made of cream
in the same time that they said let them
eat
cake they also said let them eat cream
and that's what we're gonna be making
today i'd like to welcome to the stage
uh wingus and dingus
who's ready to cream that green melted
right in
oh i found gum in my pocket
all right so we're going to be making so
we're going to be making
creme why are you standing there where
else this is your station
okay i got it now yes we are going to be
making
creme brulee
this is a complicated recipe and we take
things very seriously here so we've got
a list of
uh um uh
um ingredients no recipes
a list of recipes it's just called a
recipe
in french it's called recipe so um
what i just don't know a word on my
directions it's
french you idiot creme brulee
oh yeah i meant okay can you read the
ingredients for me
yes senor no uh monsieur
[Music]
miss your bro really step
one preheat the oven to 325 degrees
fahrenheit four celsius or celsius those
are two
different temperatures hey cereal what's
325 degrees celsius to fahrenheit 325
degrees celsius is 617 degrees
fahrenheit pretty toasty
you might be right cream and salt cook
it up step 3 add vanilla
four beat together yolks and sugar
number five combine them together
number six pour into ramekins number
seven
fill baking dish with boiling water
halfway up the sides of the ramekins not
the full way
number eight bake 30 to 40 minutes or
until
centers are barely set this is where
each chef will really take it
on their own and finally
take it out let it cool and then
refrigerate for
several hours how long did you want us
to be here
several hours and up to a couple days
i didn't read hey guys show up at one
you'll be here for a couple hours yeah
all right let's pre-heat this bad boys
oh we each get on oven no
how many of us do you think i have
wait wait actually hang on
oh operating modes it had a master
shield it's got a big
setting you learned something new every
day
[Music]
do we wrote shambo for who gets to pick
first but there's one
no i've just discovered i have more
ovens than i thought we don't have to
rochambeau nothing i don't think that
glass should be in there
there you go all right uh
i am a man who owns four
ovens i am a man
who owns four ovens
did you get that i'm a man
who owns four ovens i didn't know so i
was so rich without it
you can fix it
oven oh toasty boy four or five
i am a man who owns
five ovens i was gonna go with the one
behind me i'll take the two straw you're
gonna toast her
it's the same thing right yes same thing
wait so is that not too oven-sized
okay all right it is look man
hold on let's figure this out look man i
don't know how many ovens do you have
this is too oven this is another
microwave all right
we've gotten through step one this is
some
good [ __ ] these turn thanks man
listen i didn't know yours
let me tell you there's a reason that
i'm number five on
forbes highest paid youtubers they don't
they don't measure it
in u.s dollars they measure it
all right shut up step two
cook cream and salt
okay all right okay so
we don't we don't have any measurements
of what we're supposed to do or any this
is like
the british bake off everybody hold on
in
through one chris cook what am i helping
you guys
all right cook cream and salt
how big is it is there another sauce
dish for me
yeah is there a saucepan for me yeah
here can i have
that can i have these steals no but you
want the frying pan
no i'll take this i'll take it right the
frog
this is a pretty seasoned for me
don't drop it i'm gonna buy more
i like my creams right in the name
for those of you who don't know creme
stands for cream can i go
can i use the stove yeah all right i'm
assuming that's what cook means
i like mine creamy
[Music]
that's a low fire yeah
[Music]
[Laughter]
we're cooking the crumbs
how long do we cook it i'm going to let
mine sit for a minute
beat together yolks and sugar what why
don't you get it how do you get a yolk
is the egg separate from the yolk
all right let me show you a little thing
called cracking an egg with one hand
all right
perfect ready
can you crack an egg without cracking it
i'm going to use a half cup why can't
you wait for us oh
are we waiting no i'm just ready
what are you talking about how do you
cook cream
you wait till it's full
what does that mean cook cream
i i'm gonna just i guess
it's probably good add vanilla oh i just
forgot it
what's the next
you go first okay you need to catch up
no
i think that it's gonna be maybe
a tablespoon teaspoon table yeah
teaspoon yeah
teaspoon teaspoon yeah
these are yours yeah those are mine so
sorry you're good keep going all right
tea spoon
okay now next on my list i'd like to
really get this
right beat together
the yolks
oh i did it wrong didn't i
[Laughter]
[Music]
see that's the magnificent thing about
the kitchen we're all making
the same thing but we're getting
drastically different muscles
this seems way too watery right so does
mine
is this supposed to thicken up
i don't know i'm going to put one yoke
are you adding more deer yeah
we have different colors yeah well
did you put sugar in yours i put love in
mine oh
we have to fill this with half water
no the oh that
i'm still confused i mean i think we all
have to work together on that if all
three are going in there so
i think they're i think not we have
separate ovens
yeah oh yeah screw i call the dish
that won't fit in the toaster
i called it i got it first find another
way
i will sit on it i'll find find another
way um
why does it need boiling water i need to
cook
mine a little kitchen oh i don't even
know where it is
this is your house i need the i need
that
i need the small one it's a small one no
you don't know there's another one right
there
if you made it in a muffin tin that
would be kind of cute right
how do you get the boiling water i don't
know
this is rosanna pansino's muffin tin hey
i'm guessing that the boiling water is a
diversion
i don't i don't i don't like it when you
look at me
oh i think it's put there to trick us oh
it could be what's the difference like i
just
i splash water on it whatever i don't
think this thing's built for steam so
let's see i have like that same one i'll
make muffins i made muffins
i think i'll make muffins do these rise
i'll make muffins what are you gonna
make muffins
i'm gonna make some muffins
right right
where'd the sugar go did you pour the
water out
[Laughter]
don't be
you've never boiled water before no
one's watching it
okay hey ethan what what's
behind you oh a kettle
all right don't unplug my wi-fi
which one is the one nice pristine
yellow up in here
oh beautiful beautiful yellow
you don't put it in i don't know
all right i'm right behind you with
boiling water look out look at it look
at that oh don't
don't murder me with that hot hot soup
maybe i should use boiling water oh [ __ ]
it
i'll be the other one i'm a pioneer
were you really about to dump that into
your car yeah
i shouldn't have laughed oh my gosh
wait should i put this in there though
i'm so conflated
i'm beginning to feel that the muffin
tin was a mistake
oh that sounds boiling to me
i'm just suspect hey what the f you get
your dirty hands off of that
they're clean i lost them that's mine
mine are going in okay mine are going in
i'm gonna build this one how long did
they go in for again
read your ch sheet i've never used the
electric code before
is it on i'm going in good luck
thank you i'm written for you i
deactivated
siri hey siri
yes hey bixby
no it's hi bixby hi bixby hi bixby
i think he's watching me told you i've
never used an electric kettle before
yeah he's scared like it's gonna explode
no i'm just scared of
you i don't like how long it's taking
him to do that
don't judge my length
when you light them
and you put them together it makes a
bigger flame yeah
yeah wow it's really simple
what if you do three
oh don't check it you're at the steamer
what's happening i have two
creme brulees in the oven here look at
how pretty
they are for sure big
big boys big boisterous boys
cooking up a storm in there cooking up a
real big storm
will they be the best i'm here now well
let me then
creeper it will be in my mouth and
everyone's mouth and they'll say
oh food
[Laughter]
big big cream burn boy
it's only been 10 minutes
okay it's been um how long has it been
like
30 minutes wrong been like 24.
it's been 26 minutes and 48 seconds
i'm smart and i know exactly how long
it's been i'm also
going to pull mine out early because
mine are muffins
look at those bad boys bubble they're
supposed to bubble
definitely supposed to be bubbling that
looks
scrummy
i feel good
about these and
i think they look close to what i
imagine creme brulee looks like before
you torch it it's not
too bad it's not the worst thing in the
world
mine are lumpy
yours looks sick yours look white this
looks
like super saiyan they don't look as
yellow oh cool completely
um i got room for me
you're gonna have ice too
oh yeah wait cool completely refrigerate
for several hours
so bare minimum several hours that's
refrigerated but we're freezing we're
freezing so 30 minutes tops oh we should
turn off the oven
oh yeah i always forget that
where are your crims one minute oh come
on you can pull them out a minute
hey yeah come on no yelling at you we're
not pulling that out
pull it out pull out pull out pull up
pulling that a minute early will only be
good yeah you could if you're late
what's gonna happen
it eliminates the risk completely gotta
go now
god always pull out
[Music]
is all your water gone no no
no they look
interesting they look foamy this
is so much worse
it's fine apparently
excuse me you're so slow we're ready to
dig
outside they're completely cool
completely the heat on your glass racks
and your fridge would break it so i
can't do that
yeah don't break my glass racks
leave the door open no then it's not
getting cold
wasting the electricity oh i just
watered mine
anything could be quicker than this
we should really start making a control
for these
why something to compare and contrast i
think people know
good creme brulee when they see it when
they see
ours not that
maybe one there we go you just
enjoy a meal
don't waste the water god you're wasting
it
i'm really up with my game
[Laughter]
you think it's cooled no mine's cool
[Music]
do we sprinkle sugar on the top what do
you want to sprinkle sugar
it doesn't say sprinkle sugar on it you
should sprinkle sugar
oh you're just gonna burn it yeah what's
got sugar in it
it's got sugar in it this is what the
brule is
right do you know what brulee means yeah
sugar i don't think that this
cream sugar pretty i think brulee is
like
what does brulee mean in french
you'll need to connect to the internet
first
[Laughter]
what does brule in french mean
[Laughter]
oh i mean burned burned cream
i was right whoa
suck it get out of here this is when you
insert the spongebob several
years later i don't use those stupid
jokes
several years later
[Laughter]
you gave us no
[Music]
oh yeah
all right it's time
the big reveal brulee
just as loud over there ethan it's still
up
it's very loud i'm sorry go outside all
right
whip your [ __ ] whip it outside
my creme brulee
i'm gonna get the water out
now to get rid of the water
cleans itself oh hey wow
my boys have arrived
these look pretty good just like bread
mine smells like creme brulee mine
smells like creme brulee can i smell
now comes the most the second most
important part of
creme brulee the brulee
so afraid of you
of me you're the one that was just all
like
ethan stop nah just like this
oh stop
if you want someone to taste any of them
don't put hairspray on it also you need
to put sugar on it
for you okay
you're good i need to put
sugar no you said before that you
weren't going to
you said you said you said according to
sprinkle sprinkle
[Music]
is that enough why are you asking me
i've never made creme brulee before i
don't know
i'll do it in gradients of amount of
sugars using a lot of sugar
well now comes the brule right yeah oh
yeah
oh yeah oh yeah oh oh yeah that actually
i mean maybe it's just because you can't
burn sugar wrong but that
looks like creme brulee it looks like it
right
oh i can see it you can see it looking
out
don't tell me that you see i don't see
anything
look look at the at the right spot
do you see that no i don't you don't
oh well it was happening with you that's
it it's probably fine
it's fine okay
i'll do the rest of mine with this
is this okay probably not
should i stop no
how is it now
i'm just setting your counter on fire
perfect that worked really well voila
at least yeah bellissimo
here you feel it i feel like the flame
should be bigger i wish it lasted longer
save some for me if it works
let me get one that looks pretty good
hey that's pretty good
wait watch it bubble and voila one
that's interesting i like it who
wouldn't
and voila is that french
bellissimo that's italian yeah
stunningly
i think we have some creme brulee
i think we did it are we judging this
who's judging this are we going to try
our own
first after the taps i think so
so tap it tyler
oh
hey that's pretty good should we do a
taste test
we try we try our own first
maybe we the rule is we can't try our
own we only try the other twos
that's fair okay i'm you go first
it's it looks like creme brulee custardy
it smells good
i like it yeah yeah it's a little
more liquidy than i would expect it's
kind of like um
like pudding but it tastes good
let me try ethan's with a little whipped
cream as well
looks it looks oddly like jello
a little bit but i'm not gonna let that
dissuage me
okay
i don't like that so there was a problem
right off the bat
but it's not bad what's the problem
i was blasted with a flavor i'd never
had before
okay i'm excited but then the sugar came
and i was happy
not from the whipped cream i think it
might i'm gonna try without the whole
cream
[Laughter]
i know what that it's egg
egg so this is pretty soggy
pretty soggy smells
[Laughter]
it's not bad
it's very hmm
he keeps going back
it's so
bland that's what i thought
that's how i feel about real quick
i got a little bit of whipped cream
there so
like baked eggs with sugar it's not
it's a little weird at the end yeah but
it's not bad
okay but it's very eggy i wonder if
you'll know what
what i mean
ah
you know what i mean so that's what
those words mean
it's not bad it's not it's not
it tastes like just so painfully average
see when i've had creme brulee i felt
like there was no flavor other than the
caramelized sugar on top
that's that's how i oh it's got
something
it tastes
[Laughter]
yeah all right
i think out of all of them this is the
closest to creme brulee
it's a little it's a little salty
all right see i didn't i didn't get much
of the salt i felt a there was a good
balance
it tastes a little salty it's good
though like it tastes like creme brulee
okay all right now we try to try
right it's really hard to describe it
reminds me of like
very like lackluster vanilla flavoring
and pudding
yeah there's just not a lot of flavor
like it's not
bad though no no yeah you always say
that at the end of it
i think i think you've got a spot on it
tastes
i actually i would eat this
i'm getting that salt
[Laughter]
it's a little salty yeah it is salty
i think if i just had less salt this
should be really close
yeah i think so too it's it is runny
because but maybe
we didn't let these cool we did not know
i think we let them settle
all right you had a lot of whipped cream
oh yeah no that just tastes like egg
[Laughter]
oh yeah that's just like an egg anyone
else want to try
yeah come on come on come on in and now
is ethan's whipped cream
yeah no the whipped cream yeah stylers
which one is the safest oh if you want
purely average
i like it it's not bad yeah
it's like pudding yeah yeah that's what
i thought it was
i think the icing probably has way too
much vanilla in that one though
it's a little salty yeah it's just salty
yeah and also too sweet it's both too
salty and too sweet
all right i'm the overachiever i don't
know how you managed to do it
which is the other one that's this one
oh yeah this is the egg right
yeah this is just okay i should not end
it on this one
yep but catherine try the whipped cream
that is good i'll just take a whole
thing you know it's actually it's like
instead of whipped cream you would put
like cheese and salsa on that yeah
that is a scrambled egg with sugar on
top yeah i'm gonna try
can i try another one gross yeah sure
i don't know i think it'll be different
that was a big bite
oh no not bad goodbye goodbye
um i would say okay in ranking
i think we can just put mine at the
bottom no i wouldn't say that
all right i'll say that too
you went wrong in the recipe and we just
watched anyway so all in all
this has been creme brulee or at least
as close as we could possibly
get so thank you ethan thank you tyler
um
thank you everybody so much for watching
if you want to see more uh makes in the
future let us know what other things
that we can possibly make
in the comments below watch the other
markiplier makes i'll provide them in
the description there's a whole playlist
check them all out
thank you so much again for watching if
you even thank you tyler check out their
things
also linked in the description and as
always we'll see you
in the next video bye-bye bye